[Musica]
non ho mai vinto nulla in tutta la mia
vita davvero non ho mai vinto niente vi
posso assicurare che l'espressione è
letterale probabilmente a molti di voi
le cose saranno andate in modo
differente ma ecco io non ho mai vinto
una lotteria una pesca di beneficenza un
concorso alla radio neppure una
staffetta alle scuole elementari e anche
le mie cartelle della tombola di fine
anno sono sempre le più sfortunate poi
un bel giorno Ecco i giornali se ne
uscivano con questa notizia qui
è Forlivese il Forlivese Marco Cortese
che salivo è il campione
del mondo di plogging ora Probabilmente
molti di voi strano chiedendo che
diavolo sia il plugin bene Si tratta di
quello che i media definiscono come
l'ecosport più in voga del mondo in
sostanza nel plogging si corre ok E
mentre si corre si fa una cosa molto
strana si raccolgono i rifiuti
abbandonati che si trovano a lato della
strada vince vince chi corre più a lungo
e quindi raccoglie più immondizia
pensate avevo cominciato a fare vlogging
senza sapere neppure che avesse un nome
semplicemente perché ero stanco di
vedere l'inciviltà di tanti concittadini
imbrattare il bellissimo quartiere di
campagna nel quale vivo tre anni più
tardi partecipavo quasi per gioco alla
prima vera
olimpiade di blogging arrivando primo
nella mia categoria e non fu difficile
signori dato che a correre Eravamo solo
in due
Scherzi a parte c'era un atleti davvero
da tutto il mondo eh E gli stessi
sponsor che troverete in un super slalom
immaginate la mia gioia quando tornai a
casa per annunciare ai miei genitori la
mia vittoria internazionale mamma
Ricordatevi che solo quello che non ha
mai vinto nulla mamma mamma mamma mamma
mamma
sono campione del mondo di plogging e
mia madre campione di che diplogi ma è
che è come che è mamma mamma Corro e
raccolgo l'immondizia mia madre stava
bevendo un bicchiere d'acqua Ok scoppiò
a ridere l'acqua le andò di traverso e
stava quasi per soffocare così mio padre
disse serio queste cose qua Noi qui non
le vogliamo sapere ma ormai era fatta ad
oggi campionati a parte sono ormai
cinque anni che pratico il plogging e
credo sia stata una delle cose migliori
che sono mai capitate nella mia
esistenza e so che vi sembrerà
un'affermazione assurda ma vi posso
assicurare che è davvero così questi
ultimi cinque anni sono stati che ne so
Ai più fortunati di sempre ma di nuovo
fortunati al termine sbagliato perché
darebbe il merito alla fortuna Alla
Sorte al destino al fato mentre in
questo caso in merito va solo a un paio
di scarpe ha un sacco nero e ha una
valanga di conosciuti in questi cinque
anni gli ultimi 5 nonostante una crisi
economica una pandemia una guerra ho
realizzato più cose che negli ultimi 15
tre serie TV due film Un libro due
spettacoli teatrali ok Come diavolo è
stato possibile perché qualcosa in fondo
deve essere cambiato e pensate In
segreto non è stato un libro sapevate
che la sezione self-alp è la più
visitata di ogni Libreria del mondo pur
aumentando la percentuale di persone che
si dichiarano insoddisfatte della
propria esistenza e segreto non è stato
un Guru un workshop Il segreto non è
stata la fortuna Il segreto Ladies and
Gentleman è stata l'immondizia
quest'oggi Io vi parlerò di una cosa
molto strana che si chiama plogging ma
vedrete questo Rimanga fra me e voi che
il plogging alla fine dei conti non
c'entra poi nulla il plogging è solo un
pretesto o meglio un indizio stile
Sherlock Holmes che ci svelerà un
segreto molto più grande niente che ha
cambiato terribilmente in meglio la mia
vita e sono certo Potrà farlo anche con
la vostra E allora Che ne dite partiamo
dal principio perché io le chiamo le tre
grandi lezioni del plogging Ok Ora
arrivati a questo punto vi chiedo di
partecipare con me ad un piccolo
esperimento di immaginazione
immaginatevi con un paio di scarpe da
ginnastica ai piedi un paio di guanti e
un sacco nero Ok ora immaginate di
scendere per strada e di cominciare a
correre vi trovate nel vostro quartiere
attorno a voi stanno le strade che
conoscete e stanno le case che avete
sempre visto all'interno delle case le
persone che salutate ogni mattina e
soprattutto questa è la cosa importante
persone che vi conoscono poi scendete
per strada e cominciate correndo a fare
una cosa particolarmente strana
raccogliete le bottigliette le cartacce
tutta l'immondizia che trovate la mia
domanda è qual è la sensazione che
provate in quell'istante Qual è
l'emozione c'è chi mi dice
[Musica]
l'orgoglio Sì sono sono pervaso dal
senso civico Buon per te e come si vive
su Marte bello perché nel mio caso
invece l'emozione ha solo nome e si
chiama imbarazzo e vergogna la gente vi
giuro vi guarda come foste un folle c'è
chi sorride che si mette a ridere chi vi
indica col dito Voi vorreste schioccare
le dita e scomparire come il genio di
Aladdin Ma è proprio in quell'istante
che questo assurdo Sport chiamato
plogging sta per consegnarci la sua
prima grande lezione di vita lo fai in
una maniera terribilmente Brutale ma
allo stesso tempo terribilmente efficace
la lezione numero 1 è la seguente se
vuoi davvero arrivare da qualche parte
frega Tenete il giudizio degli altri
Questa è tostano trovate Guardate è
impossibile e vi posso assicurare sono
cinque anni che lo faccio è impossibile
raccogliere la bottiglietta se hai paura
del giudizio della gente ma vedete le
cose possono andare ben oltre è
impossibile fare quello che davvero
vogliamo fare evitando il giudizio degli
altri è impossibile essere quello che
davvero vogliamo essere evitando il
giudizio degli altri non è forse
qualcosa che abbiamo già sperimentato
nelle nostre vite anche se non stavamo
raccogliendo la bottiglietta per la
strada Quanta vita Non so voi ma io io
lo so quanta vita abbiamo sacrificato In
nome del giudizio degli altri e c'è la
mamma e il papà gli insegnanti mariti
mogli fidanzati ora avete un'idea no
Avete un sogno avete un'ambizione e la
gente la gente comincia a sorridere a
ridere e a indicarvi con il dito così vi
sentite ridicoli e pur di far terminare
questa tortura decidete Allora di fare
la cosa più stupida di tutte rinunciare
alla vostra idea al vostro sogno alla
vostra ambizione pur di far terminare
l'imbarazzo e la vergogna Ecco il blog
stato consegnato questo quando hai un
sogno gli altri scoppieranno Sempre a
ridere punteranno sempre il dito Ma in
cuor loro ti ammireranno se vuoi davvero
arrivare da qualche parte Fregatene del
giudizio degli altri e continua a
correre ok È stato difficile ma ce
l'abbiamo fatta Ok avete guardato
sorridendo il vostro vicino di casa che
vi squadrava come foste un malato di
mente Avete guardato torvi il gruppetto
di ragazzini che è scoppiato a ridere al
vostro passaggio Insomma avete fatto
vostra la prima grande lezione del
plogging ossia fregarvene del giudizio
della gente così Eccovi lì a correre con
rinnovato entusiasmo ma le difficoltà
gente non sono finite poche centinaia di
metri ed è con vecchietto di saluta
levando in alto la mano tremante e vi
faccenno di avvicinarvi
ti dovrebbero dare una medaglia vi dice
con lo sguardo bonario di un Babbo
Natale nostrano così voi annuite in
risposta ma il suo monologo non è ancora
finito perché c'è qualcosa che il
vecchietto vuole dirvi a tutti i costi
No quasi svelarvi un segreto del quale
solo lui è a conoscenza si avvicina al
vostro orecchio e sussurra Scusa se te
lo dico io ho visto che raccogli ed è
una gran bella cosa davvero Ma senti
Fidati di me non serve a niente Domani
ci saranno le stesse cartacce che hai
raccolto oggi se non di più Ladies and
Gentleman i nostri vecchietto ha
semplicemente spudoratamente
vergognosamente ragione con 8 milioni di
tonnellate di rifiuti plastici gettati
in mare ogni anno a livello globale la
bottiglietta che avete raccolto la
bottiglietta che avete raccolto meno di
una goccia in un oceano avete raccolto
una bottiglietta domani Ne avranno
gettate a terra altre 10.000 e non è
un'esagerazione è la verità quello che
state facendo non serve a niente Nada
nista Zero nulla Così la domanda è
perché lo fate allora Per quale ragione
70 tutto è sempre inutile Benvenuti alla
seconda lezione del plogging perché
sapete ci sono obiettivi e ci sono
missioni ci sono obiettivi raccogliere
la bottiglietta Ok ma ci sono anche
missioni ripulire il mondo ci sono
obiettivi spiegare l'ultima lezione di
storia i vostri ragazzi Se siete un
insegnante e ci sono missioni creare
Uomini e Donne capaci di essere veri
cittadini ci sono obiettivi preparare un
risotto allo zafferano per il tavolo
numero 5 se siete un cuoco e ci sono
missioni rendere le persone più felici
attraverso i vostri tutti la vostra
missione è la vostra Stella Polare
Qualunque sia il vostro ruolo nel mondo
ed è sempre un'utopia capite ne è sempre
realizzabile ma ha un vantaggio che i
marinai conoscono fin dalla notte dei
tempi
non si muove mai non si spegne mai ed è
la più luminosa del cielo gli altri si
smarriscono in mezzo all'oceano Ma non
voi la vostra Stella Polare là Quella è
la vostra missione non serve a niente vi
dice il vecchietto voi allora vi
avvicinate a vostra volta al suo
orecchio e sussurrate con un sorriso a
fior di labbra
lo so e poi
continuate a correre avete mai provato a
correre per 12 km con un sacco nero
condominiale che si fa gradualmente
sempre più pesante Se mai un giorno
deciderete di fare il plugin questo è
esattamente quello che vi troverete a
fare ma vi invito adesso a considerare
piuttosto la macabra crudele sadica
metafora del blogging Avete visto man
mano che il traguardo si avvicina
insacco nero non si fa più leggero No
Signore si farà sempre più pesante man
mano che stiamo per raggiungere la
nostra meta il nostro obiettivo il
nostro sogno la fatica aumenta e le
difficoltà e gli imprevisti guardatevi
attorno perché per la prima volta nella
storia dell'umanità viviamo in una
società dove viene celebrato il comfort
il vincere facile Dove dove il successo
equivale spesso a trovare il modo la
strategia il trucco per avere tanto
senza fare niente vedere dove il selfie
più virale sempre che fare con
ristoranti bei vestiti ai viaggi Ma
grazie a Dio i social non sono la realtà
potete prendere in giro i vostri
followers Ma non voi stessi Perché nella
vita reale niente di valore si raggiunge
senza un immensa devastante a volte
enorme dose di perseverance di coraggio
perché a volte con la vita è come non lo
so mi pare sia un pugile che continua a
picchiare anche quando tu hai detto ok
basta così a buttarti KO a parlarti
nell'orecchio resta il tappeto bello
resta il tappeto ti conviene Ecco questa
è la terza lezione del blog Impara la
perseveranza non arriverà mai da nessuna
parte senza fare tu alla certezza la
fede profonda che qualunque cosa succeda
anche la più brutta
anche quella che non ti saresti mai
aspettato tu continuerai a correre
Eccoci giunti alla fine di questo folle
viaggio nell'assurdo mondo del plogging
Ma sapete prima di salutarci c'è una
quarta e ultima lezione che questo
strano Sport mi ha insegnato ed è una
lezione strana perché vi ricordate
l'inizio ci riporta all'inizio di tutto
quando dicevo che il plogging alla fine
dei conti non c'entra niente c'è
qualcosa nel semplice banale gesto di
raccogliere una cartaccia da terra che
in sé una potenza disarmante perché
vedete è qualcosa che non possiamo fare
per noi stessi possiamo farlo solo per
gli altri ecco la quarta lezione la più
sottile quella apparentemente più
difficile ma anche quella più potente
Fallo per gli altri non per te stesso
fallo per gli altri e sarai
inarrestabile Fallo per gli altri quando
facciamo qualcosa per gli altri
improvvisamente svanisce la paura la
fatica la vergogna l'incertezza quando
siamo al servizio non di noi stessi ma
di qualcosa di più grande di noi di più
nobile di noi Ecco che tutto cambia
tutto diventa facile tutto diventa
chiaro grazie per aver partecipato a
questa folle corsa con un sacco nero
sulle spalle
[Applauso]
e grazie di cuore per aver prestato
attenzione anche questo strano ragionare
di uno strano tipo che non ha mai vinto
niente ad eccezione di un titolo
mondiale di indubbio valore ma
soprattutto ricordate un paio di scarpe
il sacco nero i rifiuti li trovate
ovunque e soprattutto ricordate la
lezione più importante di tutte
qualunque cosa ok qualunque cosa succeda
voi continuate a correre Grazie di cuore
Grazie mille
Marco non andava via Marco non andava
via Siamo
siamo alla fine di solito negli
spettacoli teatrali nelle performance
sei molto più esperto di noi si fa il
bis No in un qualche modo Quindi allora
ne approfittiamo abbiamo qualche minuto
di anticipo e se hai voglia di fare un
piccolo business non so qualcosa per il
pubblico quello che ti interessa a te
avevo questo bel gioco finale giusto che
mi piaceva condividere con voi perché
beh non ci si può lasciare così nel
senso che se ci pensate No questa è il
mondo del teatro No questa è quella che
chiamano la quarta parete teoricamente
no secondo Shakespeare era un po'
differente ma per gran parte del teatro
dell'Ottocento in poi qui c'è una parete
voi siete lì e noi siamo qua e
virtualmente I due mondi sono separati
invece non è così quindi volevo
condividere con voi un piccolo gioco
pensate secondo gli annali della
pedagogia teatrale è un gioco che viene
dall'Asia alcuni sono addirittura stati
gli indiani d'America Ma è un gioco che
ha veramente a che fare col fuoco che
arde e ci spingerà a scambiare il nostro
fuoco che inarcard col nostro vicino di
posto ok Quindi
Oh mio Dio era meglio non veniva però
posso assicurare molto divertente poi
veramente qualcosa che ci carica allora
vi spiego esattamente come funziona
sapevate che le mani sono pieni di un
sacco di che ne so
centri nevralgici sono meridiani
eccetera eccetera e allora il gioco ve
lo spiego E si comincia così per circa
10 secondi dobbiamo
strofinare le mani tra di loro Aspetta
aspetta ve lo spiego fino a quando
diventeranno sostanzialmente bollenti e
sarà solo la prima volta alla fine
avremo degli ustioni terzo grado
dopodiché cosa faremo primo step ci
voltiamo verso i nostri vicini di posto
e quindi Lo dovrete fare due volte ad
eccezione di chi è verso
l'esterno che avrà solo un vicino e la
prima cosa è la stretta di mano molto la
gente di vendita piacere Dopodiché
ricominciamo a strisciare per 10 secondi
diventeranno ancora più calde Dopodiché
c'è la stretta di mano quella calorosa
complimenti
e il gioco praticamente è arrivato alla
fine strisceremo per l'ultima volta
questa volta per 20 secondi Quindi
ancora più a lungo e dopo di che con le
mani realmente fuoco che arde al nostro
vicino di posto daremo un calorosissimo
abbraccio e il nostro gioco finirà qui e
potremmo dire davvero che il fuoco che è
nato qui su questo palco e che abbiamo
cercato di regalarvi ce lo siamo
trasmessi
tutti quanti insieme a qualche virus no
scherzo Speriamo di no ok Ok
allora siete pronti ovviamente il gioco
è totalmente libero e se non vi va di
farlo oppure potete continuare a
mantenere la stretta di mano
che dite allora ci siete le mani sono
queste e Uniamo le mani 10 secondi e
velocissimi uno due tre quattro cinque
Ah sei sette otto nove dieci stretta di
mano molto elegante molto distaccata
piacere ok anche l'altro vicino anche
l'altro vicino
bravissimi e ora ritorniamo Scusatemi ho
sbagliato prima questi sono 20 secondi
perché poi l'ultimo saranno 30 e 3 e 4 e
9 10 11 12 13
15 16 17 18 19 20 ok grandissima stretta
di mano Ah che piacere incontrarla buon
uomo ok anche con l'altro vicino
manteniamoci sempre su 20 che 30 non ce
la faremo mai e Ok ricominciamo a
stringere l'ultima volta riscaldate bene
le mani ora ci sarà poi super a braccio
quindi 1500 e 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13
[Musica]
19 20 Ok
Grazie di cuore
[Applauso]
[Musica]